yeah in our live chat
right good afternoon welcome to the
meeting of the auditing governance
committee
on tuesday 27th july uh item number one
is apologies for absence do we have more
apologies
yes chair and we've got apologies from
stephen
thank you very much indeed item two is
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on
tuesday the 30th of march
2021 um i'll just do a quick page turner
which paint one
page two h3
h4 h5
and six page seven
and finally page eight
there are no comments on that so if i'm
having to close from the chair i'm
looking for
a seconder from that meeting
council of great even thank you very
much all those in favor
that's the three of us who are present
thank you
i now move on to item number three which
is the declarations of
interest members with interest should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interests when the
item is considered
item four the agreement for the gen
items part one and two
so i move that
we will go in part two later on
so i'm looking for secondary from that
you